was listening to one of your podcasts
and you said garage sailing is one of
the best start right now business
experiences that you can go get it's
very practical I need to know what were
your best single flip what did you buy
for the least and sold for the most
amazing Spider-Man first appearance of
of Carnage I spent a dollar I sold it
for eighty dollars that that same day uh
I sold travel bags I bought two of them
for fifteen dollars ended up selling
them for three hundred dollars the
amount of people listening or the amount
of friends of the people listening right
now that like desperately could use
fifteen dollars to 300 is like very real
and I know right now someone's like oh
yeah but gas and eBay fee something cool
15 to 197 is like a real win for a lot
of people and it is the thrill of the
hunt we're going into that season now it
is absolutely garage sale season we need
to do it